as the war in the Middle East enters its
third week AOC is already demanding that
America accept Palestinian refugees
should Arab countries be taking on The
Lion Share of the burden to absorb what
could be over a million if not more
refugees from Gaza I think there's
something to be said about the Region's
Partners being able to support and step
up Palestinians however that does not
abdicate the United States from our
historic role that we've played in the
world of accepting refugees and allowing
people to restart their lives
here no thanks that seems like a bad
idea maybe perhaps we could consider
taking in the relatively small number of
Christians living in the Palestinian
territories not because we hate Muslims
or anything like that but because there
are lots of Arab states around the holy
land that could take the Muslims in and
America is a Christian country and even
putting Christian solidarity aside that
means means there's a good chance that
Christian refugees will assimilate and
the ability to assimilate matters
because peoples and cultures are
different and there's one more concern
which might resonate more for
AOC why would liberals want to bring
these refugees to our awful oppressive
islamophobic country all we ever hear
from the left is how terrible and evil
and oppressive America is especially
toward persons of color and Arabs and
Muslims in particular does AOC just hate
these people want to make them even more
miserable or is that argument like so
many of the liberal arguments totally
disingenuous nothing more than a
fact-free rhetorical cudgel for beating
Americans into submission to the left's
political interest I'm Michael NES this
the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Joe Biden's
brother wrote him a $200,000 check right
after one of his Shady business deal
closed uh we'll get to that in one
moment because Joe Biden keeps saying on
all of the accusations of his corruption
he keeps saying where's the money show
me the money where the go well we have a
check we have the money so we'll get to
that in one second first though I want
to remain on this point about the
differences of peoples for a while
there's a story out of Italy Italy has
this lady prime minister Georgia Maloney
heralded as a great conservative hope in
Italy and uh Maloney has just announced
that she's split from her long-term
romantic partner they were not married
but they have a kid together and they've
been together a long time uh this guy is
an Italian TV journalist and they split
because he cracked a joke with some of
his colleagues about having a threesome
or a foursome something like that it's
unclear how serious he was about
inviting the colleague to have a
threesome with him but in any case uh
Maloney said okay we're through and my
main take on the story forget about
marriage and family and what this means
about Western decadence and what put all
of that aside for a second my first
reaction to this story
is the Italians man you know a zebra
doesn't change it spots is that how the
saying goes a these the
people's this coming after Decades of
the political influence of Sylvio
Berlusconi the former Playboy Italian PM
who would hold bonga bonga parties with
with the young niece of mamar Gaddafi
and make jokes about how he had to turn
his Playboy charm on to to speak to Lady
foreign ministers and prime ministers
around the world and this guy who just
lived a lifestyle of a kazanova of of
the the classic Italian Playboy and I
think man these Italians they don't
change this has been true going back to
Antiquity because cultures and people
are different okay this is actually one
of the major themes of The Godfather in
The Godfather you got this Italian
family and they come to America and they
believe in America and we all believe in
America and they're going to assimilate
and you got the young Michael Corleone
the the son who even if the rest of his
family is going to be in the business of
the mob he's going to be the cleancut
American War hero he's going to go to
Dartmouth he's an Ivy League graduate
he's going to be the American as Don
corani says to him you you're going to
be the Senator Michael you're you're not
going to be buying off the Senators
you're going to be the senator you're
going to be the American guy but the
culture just pulls him back in just when
he thinks he's out it pulls him back in
the pull of culture the pull of one's
tribal identity from the family all the
way up to the nation and a People is
very very strong and what m
multiculturalism and liberalism has told
us for the past many decades now five or
six decades is that peoples are all
basically the same so you can transplant
a guy from timbuk 2 into America and
within five minutes he's going to be
eating hot dogs on the 4th of July and
eating apple pie and indistinguishable
from somebody whose family came over 400
years ago and that's just not true
assimilation is very very hard and
that's something we need to keep in mind
when AOC is suggesting that we need to
import a million people the majority of
whom elected Hamas in 2006 not a good
idea not going to be very good for
American Prosperity when you want to
think about your own material Prosperity
you got to check out Birch gold right
now Tex NS to 98 9898 the G20 or group
of 20 is an international forum for
governments and Central Bank Governors
it was established in response to the
financial crisis of the late 1990s with
the aim of promoting International
Financial stability last month the G20
announced a plan to impose digital
currencies and digital IDs on their
respective populations Central Bank
digital currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase you
make even if you don't follow
International economic policies all that
closely you should be concerned and you
should consider diversifying at least
some of your assets into physical gold
with the help of Birch gold group call
Birch gold today to preserve your
savings in a tax sheltered retirement
account if you have an IRA or 401K from
a previous employer call Birch gold and
they will help you convert it into an
IRA in Gold you will not pay a penny out
of pocket they will simply convert that
401k that would otherwise be sitting in
a bank somewhere into physical gold that
can't be tampered with text Noles canes
to 98 9898 Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on gold if digital
currency becomes a reality you will be
glad to have something physical to fall
back on text nolles KES to 98 9898 claim
your free info kit on gold today
speaking of Palestine and assimilation
is's a a photo that went viral I think
Libs of Tik Tok our great friends over
there posted it uh it's of a guy a sort
of vaguely Brown looking fellow with a
kefia around his neck not on his head
but around his neck holding up a sign
that's one of the versions of the gay
flag and it says queers for
Palestine and everyone's attacking this
guy mocking him I want to have a
different take
here I'm with him I stand with him I
strongly support sending all American
LGBT activists
to the Palestinian territories
immediately I know that we have a
spending problem here we've got major
deficits a whole lot of national debt I
don't care money is No Object I am
strongly in favor of of Congress
allocating funds to send every single
American LGBT activist not just the
ordinary people who kind of do some
weird stuff in the privacy of their own
but I'm like the activist types you know
the ones with the signs and the flag and
the yelling and the screaming and the
changing our curricula and our standards
and public life the I want to send every
single one of them to Palestine
immediately if we need to send them with
first class airfare I'm fine allocating
that money as well whatever it takes we
need to support the queers for
Palestine now the queers for
Palestine probably don't know a ton
about
Palestine and
how their behaviors will be received
there but they can find out uh firsthand
I I don't want to ruin the surprise for
them speaking
of queers just the queers generally uh
Maxim has just named
[Music]
a now speaking of digging deeper where's
the money where's the money proving that
Joe Biden is a crook and was pedaling
American influence overseas to enrich
himself and his family where's the money
Jack come on Corn Pop show me the check
well we got the check James comr who's
running the house committee on oversight
and accountability has revealed bank
records that that show a $200,000 direct
payment from James and Sarah Biden Joe's
brother and sister-in-law to Joe Biden
in
2018 James Biden got $600,000 in loans
from americor americor was a financially
distressed and failing rural Hospital
operator so goes to bankruptcy Court
bankr Bankruptcy Court says that James
Biden received these loans quote based
upon representations that his last name
Biden could quote open doors and that he
could obtain a large investment from the
Middle East based on his political
connections which was probably true so
James Biden gets the $600,000 loan on
March 1st 2018 americore wired a
$200,000 loan into James and Sarah
Biden's personal bank account
not their business bank account so you
got 600 is the big number 200 goes
directly to the personal bank account of
the brother of the now president of the
United States and on that same day James
Biden writes a $200,000 check from that
same personal bank account to Joe
Biden what more evidence could we
possibly have that Joe is taking
bribes there's there's no more you
couldn't have a more Smoking
Gun in a way I'm kind of surprised that
Joe was this sloppy I figured that as a
crook he would have at least hid the
money a little bit better one or two
more shell companies before going
basically just straight into his
brother's personal bank account straight
from that not even from a different bank
account from that bank account to Joe
that's all the evidence you need I mean
we had all the evidence we needed when
we got the hunter Biden laptop where
Hunter Biden is saying yeah we're giving
10% to the big guy sometimes I got to
give half my salary to my dad I'm not
going to do that to you though
kids yeah I'm I'm The Bag Man for the
Biden family is essentially what he was
saying we already knew all of that and
it doesn't really matter the reason it
doesn't really matter is because of a
crisis of regime that we're
facing we nominally live in a democracy
sometimes people draw a distinction
between a republic and a democracy but
broadly speaking we're talking about the
same thing government of the People by
the people for the people but there's a
dark side to democracy which is Mob
rule just as you can have a monarchy but
you can have a dark side to monarchy
which is tyranny just as you could have
an an aristocracy which is theoretically
good Aristo means good supposed to be
government by Good People small group of
good people but governing for the common
good the bad side of aristocracy is
oligarchy what distinguishes the good
from the bad version of all of these
regimes what distinguishes it is whether
you are governing for the common good or
for your
self-interest that that's the classical
distinction going all the way back to
the ancient Greeks going back to
pus in modern political philosophy
people make uh make less of this
distinction Thomas Hobbs famously said
that that distinction is basically bunk
and we just we just view our own regimes
as good and other people's regimes as
bad but I think the distinction is
pretty pretty real there have been good
mon throughout history and there have
been tyrants throughout history there
have been good democracies throughout
history and then there have been States
run by mob rule the problem here is the
American democracy such as it is has
already decayed so significantly that
people are ruling openly for
self-interest and so this $200,000 check
is not going to bother the Democrats
because the Democrats are going to say
well at least he's our guy at least he's
on our side yeah he's he's enriching
himself but who cares he's going to
enrich me too he's going to give me
handouts he's going to punish my enemies
he's going to let me and my friends off
the hook for committing the same or
Worse crimes as the conservatives and
the Republicans so yeah he's governing
out of self-interest but he's our guy
and we're governing out of self-interest
too this is the the line of I think it
was HL Menin who said democracy is the
theory that the people know what they
want and they deserve to get it good and
hard now when you want to talk to your
fellow citizens and deliberate and
persuade them and one hopes govern for
the common good you got to start out by
talking to them and that's why you need
to check out P talk right now go to Pur
talk.com P talk recently announced that
they would alleviate $10 million in
veteran debt by Veterans Day thanks to
your support last week Pure Talk is 53%
to their goal with two weeks to go now
think about this we have a 100%
volunteer military men and women who
raise their hands to sacrifice for this
country and when they're done serving
they come back to a tight job market and
an outrageous cost of living expenses
that is why I I'm so happy a private
company like P talk has jumped into help
when you switch to P Talk's Lightning
Fast 5G Network they will donate a
portion of every new order to this noble
cause you can make a real difference
just by choosing Superior cell phone
service P talks plans start at just 20
bucks a month offering unlimited talk
text more data and mobile hotspot just
go to Pur talk.com canw to make the
switch let's rally together and show our
unwavering support for our veterans that
is Pur talk.com canw switch to pure talk
today it is the right move and it is the
American way speaking of national
leadership sorry to report Jim Jordan is
out of the race for Speaker of the House
in a way I'm happy to report this
because I like Jim Jordan and I think
Jim Jordan is a good guy and I wouldn't
want to wish the worst job in Washington
DC on him but he would have been a good
speaker would have been great for
conservatives anyway he's out couldn't
get the votes so now we have new people
in the race one of whom is the young
Byron Donald's I am a candidate
officially uh we put out a notice on our
ex that telling the American people and
my colleagues that I've thrown my hat in
the ring to run for speaker of the house
look let's be very clear our house right
now we're having some issues uh we can
repair those issues but it requires us
to be unified number one go back to
business and secure our border actually
fund this government responsibly and
then continue to lay out that
conservative vision for the people who
sent us here that job can still be done
um I believe I am the leader that can
get that job done that's why I threw my
hat in the ring to run for speaker of
the house he's in the race he's in the
House Freedom caucus so he's siding with
the conservatives he's uh close to
president Trump he is a favorite of at
least a good portion of the GOP base 44
years old he was first elected to
congress only a few years ago so
obviously ambitious guy his critics are
going to knock him and say he doesn't
have the experience he's too new he
doesn't know how to work the lever of
power for speaker of the house that's
maybe the most important thing to do any
kind of congressional leadership you got
to know what buttons to push what levers
to pull so it'll be hard I think for him
to get the requisite
support but on the flip side any
congressman who vote against him are
racist those are the rules now those are
the ru I didn't make the rules the libs
made the rules but those are the rules
thisy this guy could be the first first
black Speaker of the House of
Representatives and so anyone who votes
against him is a big
racist and that's
that it's good for the goose is good for
the gander if it gets us a republican
speaker you know that's fine the word
racism doesn't mean anything anymore so
I don't even think it's dishonest it's
just like calling someone a flimy flam
FL doesn't I don't know it doesn't mean
it's not dishonest to call someone that
just doesn't mean anything so okay you
vote against Byron Donald's you're
racist there are other candidates for
speaker actually as of this morning I
think everyone is running I think I'm I
think I'm running Matt might be running
uh Candace Brett she's in Hungary right
now she's probably running for speaker
though every Republican in the world is
running for speaker the first few guys
though to throw their hats in well
you've got Byron Donald's then you got a
few other people you got uh
representative Kevin Hearn he's the
chairman of the Republican study
committee you've got Congressman Jack
Bergman he's an impressive guy former
Marine Corps Lieutenant General he's
been in office since
2017 uh you got Pete session Pete
Sessions has been in Congress for a long
time he served for 11 terms but he he
was defeated in 2018 and then he got
reelected in 2020 and sessions also
formerly ran the national Republican
Campaign Committee so uh he was in
leadership Doling out money that might
give him a slight Advantage though it
was a long time ago he ran the nrcc back
in uh 2009 to
2013 so you know what have you done for
me lately does prevail on Capital
Hill I I don't know who's going to win
it and there are about a billion other
people who are going to jump in the race
too the thing that surprises me most
about this is that these are all pretty
solid
guys maybe sessions just by virtue of
having been there for a long time and
having been around leadership maybe he's
got a little bit of the upper hand maybe
I'm not even convinced of that but these
are all pretty pretty conservative
pretty solid guys all four of these guys
are at least as solid I think actually
significantly more solid and
conservative than the previous speakers
we've had then Kevin McCarthy then Paul
Ryan then John Boehner maybe even the
nuk inrich I really like nuk inrich but
90s were a different time but he had
some liberal eccentricities when he was
speaker that's not a bad situation for
us to be in we need a speaker though and
if this works if we end up getting an
effective conservative speaker of the
house then Matt Gates's stunt will have
been worth it it will have been
Vindicated if we don't and we end up
with some squish compromise candidate
that that the Democrats are
controlling then things will not be
looking very good for Congressman Gates
now speaking of candidates RFK Jr has
just come out and
endorsed some form of reparations for
slavery and I love this story I love
this story some conservatives are really
upset by it I'm not I'm so happy about
it here's what he
said he said we need federal tax dollars
to quote rebuild black infrastructure
like Banks and businesses he supports
quote direct redress payments or tax
credits uh to black people for by virtue
of being black he says communities that
were specifically targeted for
Destruction need to be specifically
targeted for repair during Jim Crow
black Banks businesses hospitals schools
and Farms were targeted for Destruction
racists knew that without these the
black community had no chance of
Building Wealth we must set aside
federal dollars to rebuild black
infrastructure these programs compliment
ment direct redress payments or tax
credits to the descendants of the
victims of Jim Crow and other victims of
persecution RFK Jr will find ways to
offer this redress that are legal fair
and win the approval of Americans of all
Races okay you know I hate to say I told
you
so I called it I called it when
Americans and when the right-wingers in
particular were saying RFK Jr he's a
right-winger that guy he's he's a
Conservative candidate we should back
him over Trump or disantis or somebody I
said he's a Li he's a liberal that's no
knock on him exactly he's always been a
liberal his name's Kennedy he just sides
with us on coid vaccines which is good
but there are other issues you know like
the economy and uh abortion and
immigration and National Security and
like everything and everything and he's
with the Liberals on pretty much
everything environmentalism
energy and he happens to be with us on
coid
vaccines to to rfk's point the actual
point he's arguing here he says that
black people were treated unfairly so we
need to give them money in different
forms of course that was the point of
the expansion of the welfare state in
the 60s that was the point of the Great
Society that was the point of the laws
that followed the Civil Rights Act it
was about transferring wealth and
investing in Black infrastructure and
giving handouts and tax credits and
different sorts of things specifically
to black people and it didn't really
improve things at
all so when you hear about a Kennedy
Democrat this is what this is exactly
what we're talking about the Kennedy
Democrats have not changed one iota
since the
1960s the problem is those policies from
the 1960s didn't help anything and in
many ways they they hurt the country and
the position of black people so it's
just more of the same but the other
reason I love this story is we've been
told that from all the Geniuses even on
the right they say oh if if RFK Jr runs
he's going to take votes from Trump and
and the reason that people have said
that is because Trump Trump he's a
Kookie populist and RFK Jr he's a Kookie
populist and the Kookie populists are
going to take votes from one
another the people who have the opinion
that RFK Jr was going to take more votes
from Trump than from Biden are the kind
of people who really don't like Trump
and they write off Trump as some
eccentric populist unored man who has no
principles whatsoever who just appeals
to the basest of petitive elements in
society that's not my view of trump I
like some of the other Republicans too
but I I also like Donald Trump and I
have long thought that Donald Trump
appeals to a basically
coherent in fact rather traditional kind
of American conservatism and there's a
coherence to his political program even
if he sometimes says things that are
somewhat contradictory or eccentric and
therefore if a liberal comes around he's
not going to be able to pull the wool
over the eyes of trump voters that Trump
voters are not as gullible and de
horable and irredeemable and whatever
else The Establishment tells us as the
establishment might have us believe and
then guess what you see
polls polling Americans even in certain
decisive places on who they would vote
for if it were Trump versus Biden and
then who they would vote for if it was
Trump versus Biden versus RFK Jr and
guess who RFK Jr takes more votes from
Guess Who hates to say I told you so it'
be me I'm the one who did it speaking of
the Republican primary Ronda santis
looking really really good over the
weekend as he evacuates him himself
evacuates more Americans from the Holy
Land as War breaks out happy to report
we had another flight bringing
Floridians back from Israel land in the
wee hours of the morning we've been able
to help hundreds of people get back uh
from the war zone safely to the United
States to the State of Florida uh We've
also put a lot of supplies that have
been donated over to Israel and I know
they're really appreciative of it and
we've got another flight coming uh most
likely tomorrow morning so federal
government dragged its feet a lot of
those folks didn't have any options we
stepped up showed the leadership and are
delivering
results this is the best thing Dan
santis can do for his campaign because
it it's also the thing that's going to
give him a path if this primary doesn't
go his
way Ronda santis is never going to beat
Donald Trump at the Charisma game
nobody is it's not it's not even a knock
on Des santis nobody is Ronda santis is
not going to beat Donald Trump on the
rhetoric game the santis might have more
controlled or disciplined rhetoric it's
not as exciting Ronda santis is never
going to beat Donald Trump on the debate
game Trump's not even gonna go to the
debates D santis is not going to beat
Donald Trump on the rally game Trump's
always going to have more exciting
rallies the thing that Ron santis can
do is get results from his political
office Donald Trump does not currently
have a political office Ronda santis
does so Donald Trump I guess could send
his airplane to LIF as a private citizen
to lift people out of Israel might be
kind of difficult to do Ronda Sanz is
governor of Florida with potentially
constituents and family members of
constituents in the Holy Land he can
send airplanes over there and he can get
results done and
what's great about that strategy is one
if Trump stumbles he'll be able to point
to I've been doing this I've been doing
that I've been very effective I've been
doing my job I'm not just selling out my
second term as Florida Governor to run
for president I'm still getting stuff
done which he's doing and if the primary
doesn't go his way he'll he'll he won't
have completely blown his career on one
failed bid for
president he'll still be able to point
to momentum and achievements he can make
the most of his time in the office that
he's sitting in especially as the
election does not the presidential
election does not appear to be going his
way speaking of evacuating the Holy Land
some good news two American hostages
have been released by Hamas these are
two a mother and a daughter dual
citizens of Israel in the United States
uh they were freed on Friday Hamas
turned them over according this
according to a spokesperson for uh the
Israeli Prime Minister's office is
really great news thank God wonderful
that they've been
least there are still over 200
hostages
and until the hostage situation is dealt
with the war is only going to escalate
there's there's
nothing that is still just such a tense
Point they've got to deal with that
problem before you can resolve the
war this would never have happened under
Trump I don't want it to seem like I'm
just Shilling for Trump or something
this probably wouldn't have happened
under any Republican president but it
definitely wouldn't have happened under
Trump in the same
way that this kind of thing wouldn't
have happened most likely under
Reagan don't forget in 1980 we were
dealing with the Iran hostage crisis for
a very very long time and then the day
that Ronald Reagan is inaugurated
president the Iranians released the
hostages which was a big middlefinger to
Carter but it it also I think expresses
the legitimate fear that Ronald Reagan
was a cowboy and was unpredictable in
his foreign policy and Donald Trump took
that principle up to 11 Donald Trump's
unpredictability was so clear and he
talked like a dove and then he would
drop the Moab he would say he doesn't
want any more Wars he'd be hugging Kim
Jong-un and then he'd take out the top
Iranian General you just didn't know
what the guy was going to do and if
there was a 5 to 10% chance that he was
going to blow you to smithin then you
behaved and you didn't you didn't get
too
feisty during the four years of the
Trump Administration that is the only
time in in the last 22 years that
Vladimir Putin didn't invade a new
country or didn't go further into a
country he' already invaded it's the
only time in those years that we didn't
have new Wars breaking out in the Middle
East you actually had peace agreements
being signed in the Middle East that you
had you had relatively Global Peace and
it's amazing how quickly things can fall
apart we are now in the brink of World
War II we still have hostages
overseas amazing how quickly things can
fall part and the question is can you
restore things just as quickly if Trump
gets reelected or if Trump loses the
primary and Ronda santis gets elected or
V gets elected or Nikki or
whoever can
you restore what has been broken that
quickly maybe maybe it's much harder to
do maybe you could but it better happen
fast because the world is descending
into global conflict are you still
getting your chocolate from woke company
well you should get Jeremy's chocolate
instead right now you can say big with
30 30% off our famous he him with nuts
where's the nuts one that's this one
one's got nuts and the she her which is
nutless do you get it do you get it get
yours in the full size or our sharable
microaggression size perfect for giving
out to friends family and neighbors time
is running out today is your last chance
to stock up now in time for Halloween go
to Jeremy chocolate.com today
my favorite comment on Friday is from
Michelle mcdermit 75 who saysi know
Michael's show is mostly watched by the
younger generation but this 75-year-old
Italian grandmother loves watching I'm
so honored to hear that and by the way
Michelle this show is for all ages it's
for all sort we some some shows in
politics and especially on the right
they 90% Target young people our show is
enjoyed by all sorts of people in fact I
was very privileged to H go to have some
pizza with some Dominican sisters over
the weekend it was very nice and I found
out that a sister not of the Zoomer or
Millennial or even Gen X generation a
sister of a certain age watches the show
regularly and I was so honored by that
and I realized I got to make sure that I
have properly formed content based on
solid philosophical and Theological
principles and we keep this show
wholesome this is a family show no
language but I'm I'm really honored that
we can get the UTS and the Italian
grandmothers and lots of people in
between speaking of Israel Palestine
this is a story that was going around
last week meant to get to it then but
I'll get to it now is a pizzeria in Gaza
the Eiffel Bakery and
Supermarket or I guess actually okay
it's located in Judea and
Samaria the pizzeria post posted an
advertisement of one of the the hostages
who happened to have been a holocaust
Survivor holding a pizza and it was
basically mocking this hostage and then
uh Israel decided to completely destroy
the
pizzeria understandably
So This Is War and Israel sees one of
the hostages being mocked by this
private business and Israel just goes in
and levels the pizzeria I get it if I
were the prime minister I very likely
would have done the same
thing but what is the legal basis for
that what is the legal basis for
leveling the pizzeria I don't think
anyone's claiming that the pizzeria was
housing Hamas leaders or weapons or
anything like
that the justification for leveling the
pizzeria is because they were mocking
this hostage and that's that's extremely
provocative and Israel and the pal
Palestinian territories are at War right
now and in
war people break things that's the
argument but that's a reminder too we
are in allout war and you're going to
hear all sorts of legal justifications
and all kinds of arguments for why this
side is doing this or that side is doing
some other
thing This Is War and there is deep deep
enmity here between these peoples that
goes back
Millennia and has been inflamed recently
by the Hamas terror attack that killed
over a thousand Israelis and things are
going to get really really ugly and it
is just a reminder to me of something
I've been saying repeatedly since the
war broke out which
is the US interest in the war in the
Middle East is to contain the
war that's not the Palestinian interest
the Palestinian interest is to destroy
the state of Israel that's not the
Iranian interest the Iranian interest is
to destroy the state of Israel it's not
the is isi interest the Israeli interest
is essentially to destroy the
Palestinian territories and maybe to
have regime change in
Iran that's not the Saudi interest or
the Syrian interest or the Lebanese
interest or the this interest we have
different interests here okay that's
understandable nations are different
peoples are different they're in
different parts of the world and they've
got they've got different strategic
interests but ours remains to contain
the war before it spirals out of control
if it hasn't
already now speaking of the role of
Reason in human behavior I've got a very
stupid article that just came out this
is from a Stanford University Professor
Robert sapolsky he's a neurobiologist
he's a winner of the MacArthur genius
Grant which often goes to Big Libs I
think that guy tan heesy coat's got it
it's where they basically give you like
half a million dollars or more might be
half a million dollars a year to just
spout your inanities and it tends to FOC
focus on Libs uh Robert spolski at
Stanford says that as a result of his
studies he has concluded there is no
Free Will and here's his argument he
says the world is really screwed up and
made much much more unfair by the fact
that we reward people and punish people
for things they have no control over
we've got no free will stop attributing
stuff to us that isn't there so he's not
just saying that we punish people for
the ordinary things that we have no
control over you know we do something
accidentally or we've got some impulse
that we can't quite control or we're
mentally deficient or you know children
have no impulse control very little so
we're not he's saying anything we do
anything is something that we have no
control over because we have no control
over anything at all the article goes on
if it's impossible for any single neuron
or any single brain to act without
influence from factors beyond its
control supulski argues there can be no
logical room for free will and there we
see it because what is his argu what is
his argument for us having no free will
is it that he's discovered
some bizarre fact that we act before our
conscious thought kicks in you sometimes
hear those arguments against free will
they're pretty dubious do you do you
hear that I don't know did he discover
some magical cell that I don't know that
told him we don't have any free will no
none of that what he discovered is
that we are influenced by things that
are not consciously our own choice and
autonomy which like duh yeah obviously
we live in in the world and we're
influenced by any number of things we're
influenced by our friends by our family
by our upbringing by the the beliefs
that we were raised in by the weather by
our by everything yeah we're we're
influenced by all sorts of things how
does that negate free will
it negates Free Will and I I see how
this MacArthur genius could fall into
this trap it negates free will if you
believe that freedom is total autonomy
that's what the Liberals believe that's
what that's what we in our civilization
have believed for the last few hundred
years that that freedom is just the
perfect autonomy over our body and
Perfect Choice that's not what freedom
is that's not the classical conception
it's not the Christian conception of
freedom
the classical conception is that freedom
derives from willingness just willing
things and will presupposes reason so if
you're if you've got a strong reason if
you if your intellect is
well-formed and if your will is welld
disciplined such that you can resist
taking the third cookie after dinner
such that you can resist from sleeping
with the girl at the bar such that you
have control over your appetites if your
will and your intellect are well formed
then you can be said to be quite free
but if they're not if you're extremely
ignorant and you're poorly educated mean
you're poorly brought up you you've
fallen into all sorts of vices you
haven't practiced virtues your will is
very compromised you can't you can't see
a drink without having the drink you
can't see a girl without sleeping with
the girl you can't resist any of your
base appetites even if you consciously
don't want them then you are not free
then you're a slave then you're then you
are a slave to your own
Passions
being influenced by outside
forces will depend on how well-formed
your your will and your intellect are if
you've been brought up the right way and
you practice virtue then even if you
know some hot lady walks in the room
naked and tries to seduce you you can
chase her out of the room like Thomas
aquinus did with a torch say get out of
here lady I don't want you even if
someone hands you drugs and booze and
all sorts of things you can say no I
don't want any of
that that's freedom the the very fact
that this Stanford Professor this genius
alleged genius says that if you're
you're influenced by something that
means you're not free shows you how
degraded our will and our intellect have
become in our society especially among
the so-called intellectuals you know the
rest of the show continues now we have a
a song from music Monday that I've been
told to mention was picked by producer
Dany so if you hate the song do not send
your death threats to Mr Davies do not
send your death threats to Professor
Jacob producer Danny is responsible the
show continues now go to dailywire.com
use code noes at checkout for 2 months
free on all annual
[Music]
plans